[Music]
what's up wisecrack
michael here and today we're talking
about cinema's other coin flipping
nihilist
while most agree that no country for old
men is brilliantly made
somewhere frustrated to see a
high-octane western end with an
unsatisfying monologue about dreams and
not with a hotly anticipated showdown
how'd you sleep i don't know had dreams
well you got time for them now anything
interesting
there always is to the party concerned
so what gives
what on earth does this conclusion mean
and why did the film end not with a bang
but with a whimper
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
on the philosophy of no country for old
men
and as always spoilers ahead all right
guys let's do a quick recap
adapted from author cormic mccarthy's
2005 novel of the same name
no country kicks off when cowboy
llewellyn moss stumbles across a desert
drug deal gone wrong in a moment of
weakness moss steals a briefcase
that contains two million dollars of a
large corporation's money
prompting them to send ruthless murderer
anton chagur after him
meanwhile aging sheriff ed tom bell is
tasked with following sugar's grizzly
trail in an attempt to reach moss before
chigurh does the corporation sends
another train killer after moss and a
mexican cartel makes its own grab for
the cash
killing moss in the process there are
more gruesome slayings the money
vanishes and chigar gets away
prompting a despondent sheriff bell to
hang up his spurs
in the end bell reflects on what
happened and muses on a pair of
seemingly
unrelated dreams cut to black part one
classic westerns to understand what
exactly is going on in this movie we'll
have to start at the beginning
in the film's early scenes the coen
brothers borrowed tropes from the
classic western genre
take the opening sequence in which
sweeping landscapes are contrasted with
roads power lines and other man-made
structures
a juxtaposition common in classic
westerns that highlights the american
settlers struggle
to tame a chaotic wilderness similarly
classic westerns often deal with justice
as settlers attempt to erect societies
and administer law and order
these movies rely on neat binary
archetypes and symbols
film scholar will wright lists some of
these simple oppositions in his book
six guns in society a character is
inside or
outside of society strong or weak
good or bad these clear divisions imply
an absolute morality that the lawmen
must justly enforce
enter sheriff ed tom bell who wears an
actual white hat
a classic indicator of virtue and comes
from a long line of sheriffs
grandfather was a law man father too
throughout the story bell believes that
as an
agent of the law he is bound by a strict
moral code what is it
says about truth and justice oh we
dedicate ourselves daily anew something
like that
i'm going to commence dedicating myself
twice daily it might come to three times
before it's over with
belle is an almost flat representation
of the justice seeking good sheriff
in contrast anton chagura seems to
represent the classic western bad guy
he's dressed in black when we first meet
him he's in handcuffs
immediately indicating his lawlessness
oh and if you weren't sure he does
this later we see sugar shoot a bird for
no reason
another hallmark of the western villain
often called a kick
the dog moment famous examples of this
include the searchers
[Music]
and hondo all of which feature bad guys
killing or abusing a dog
letting us know that they are the worst
this trope is also spoofed in blazing
saddles
and even in the coen brothers own
raising arizona so at first glance it
seems like no country could be a classic
western
but the cohens quickly complicate things
part two
revisionist westerns sheriff bell's
opening monologue hints that times have
changed and so is crime you can't help
but compare yourself against the
old-timers
i couldn't help but wonder how they'd
operated these times later
he and wendell find the burning car
trigger left behind and when bell
theorizes that trigger changed vehicles
they have this exchange that's very
linear sheriff
agent flatten the man wendell here bell
acknowledges that this
old dog can't keep up with the new
tricks of the modern west
in other words belle a relic from
classic western's past
can't comprehend this new reality which
seems to be more akin to the next phase
of western films
revisionist westerns starting in the
1950s and 60s
westerns began to shift away from
focusing on lawmen to focusing on
outsiders and anti-heroes these movies
sometimes called
revisionist westerns depict a morally
gray or morally relativistic world
in which people have to adapt to survive
in his book the six gun mystique sequel
historian john g
kalady explains that revisionist
westerns often display
critical and ironic attitudes towards
some of the most traditional myths
associated with the western such as that
of the heroic gunfighter
in other words revisionist westerns are
modern stories in a classic western
setting
that grapple with america's
disillusionment and soul searching
so in no country for old men belle is
juxtaposed with llewellyn moss
the actual hero or rather the
revisionist western anti-hero of the
story who does dubious things like steal
briefcases full of money but then
returns to the crime scene to bring a
dying guy some water
rather than a white hat-wearing paragon
of justice moss is an
opportunist attempting to navigate a
morally ambiguous world
another kick the dog moment further
distinguishes our two heroes
early on moss is forced to shoot an
aggressive dog
minutes later when belle and wendell
arrive at the scene of the drug deal
they're horrified that the bad guys also
killed a dog
oh hell's bell they even shot the dog
one that looks nearly identical to the
one moss shot
here bell's clear-cut ideology is
complicated by the morally ambiguous
situation
moss encountered another important
aspect of revisionist westerns
has to do with the nature of justice in
these movies justice often takes the
form of
karma or a you reap what you sow kind of
cyclical retribution
rather than coming from the law thus
people who live by violence
often die by violence we see this
version of justice when moss on the
verge of death
crosses into mexico and is extorted for
money look you gotta give me this money
i got no other reason to protect you the
scene creates a kind of cyclical moral
logic
moss is reaping what he has sown when he
wakes up in mexico
the song a mariachi group sings
translates to you wanted to fly without
wings
you wanted to touch the sky you wanted
too much wealth
you wanted to play with fire in the
revisionist western tradition
no country seems to suggest that justice
might come from outside the law
but it does still exist and is
understandable
but there are still elements that
complicate this understanding
and perhaps suggest that there is no
justice to be had
part 3 chaos reigns
let's get back to sugar at first he
seems to be a flat traditional villain
but he's actually
much more complex take this pivotal gas
station scene
a traditional baddie would just murder
the station owner but instead
choker leaves the man's fate up to
chance is something wrong with the world
with anything
is that what you're asking me is there
something wrong with anything
here he mocks the very notion of right
or wrong
in other words sugar is not in fact a
strictly evil force
but rather an agent of chaos similarly
although we see triger shoot the bird in
a classic kick the dog moment
then next time he encounters an animal
the cat in the hotel he leaves it alive
chigurh's actions again seem random and
don't follow any apparent rules
except the rule of unmitigated chaos
sugar explains this to carla jean moss
at the end of the film
when he insists that she call a coin
toss to decide her fate
carlo jean attempts to reason with sugar
but he rejects her logic
call it the coin don't have no say
it's just you
i got here the same way the coin it in
jakur's mind
there is no order only chance another
way to cohen so chaos is by introducing
interlopers
characters who functionally introduce
unpredictability or
chance author h.h monroe aka saki
popularized this idea with his 1911
short story
the interlopers in the tale two men face
off in the forest to settle a family
feud
but after getting pinned under a fallen
log the men instead make peace
only to both get eaten by wolves the
eponymous interlopers
at the end in no country for old men
there are many interlopers who randomly
and unexpectedly
interfere with the plot we meet our
first interloper right at the outset
mosh shoots a deer but a black dog comes
out of nowhere and steals the wounded
animal for himself
in fact the dying man moss encounters
warns him
that more interlopers lurk nearby i
lobos
there are wolves moss insist no lobos
but when he goes back to bring the dying
man some water he does indeed encounter
wolves
in the form of the mexican drug cartel
who function throughout the story
as unpredictable interlopers clearly in
the cohen's west
chaos reigns but the film's strongest
rejection of all western tropes
really coalesces in the third act as
things get even weirder
sugar has the opportunity to reclaim
moss's stolen money
but he's like nah you can have the money
anton
why because as we've seen chager isn't
here to make money
or sense his violence is chaotic and
nihilistic
and rooted largely in the notion that
fate is an uncontrollable force ruling
over all our lives
enter the neo-western note that genre
terms are constantly contested by
theorists
who might call no country a new western
late western
post-modern western or any other number
of terms that exist to make us feel a
little crazy
but others consider it just to be the
next phase
of the revisionist post-western
tradition but we're going to use the
term neo-western
as it's conventionally understood to
mean contemporary-ish stories
that incorporate generic western themes
and tropes to critique
the mythos of the west while also
incorporating other genres ranging from
noir
to horror so anyway the neo-western of
which no country is basically a poster
child
is often characterized by a much darker
vision of the american west
importantly as scholar lee clark
mitchell explains in his book
late westerns these films will typically
trust that its viewers
understand the language of the western
and use our familiarity
to undercut our expectations because the
cohens know that we'll register the
cinematic language of the film
from the stetson boots to the
distinctive texan draw as western
they can have fun playing with our minds
and hearts this is where we need to note
that
neo-westerns including no country often
pull heavily from the traditions of
another classic american film genre
film noir this is nothing new for the
coen brothers who have been called
the epitome of the neo-noir impulse in
the 21st century
their genre [ __ ] instincts are
certainly on parade in no country
this is clear from the opening sequence
we already went over the way wide angle
shots of sprawling landscapes are shown
to situate us in a comfort zone of the
classic western
at the same time though these images are
accompanied by sheriff bell's
90-second voice-over about his own life
feelings
and reactions to societal violence he
killed a 14-year-old girl
paper said it was a crime of passion but
he told me there wasn't any passion to
it
this technique is far more
characteristic of noir films
which frequently make use of voice over
to establish mood
and give insights into the psychological
plight of a protagonist
you say to yourself how hot can it get
an acapulco you find out
i knew she had to wind up here because
if you want to go south here's where you
get the ball
this immediately establishes the two
genres with which the film will wrestle
the cohen's noir intentions are also
signaled to us when carla jean watches
flight to tangier
on a black and white tv a classic noir
film that actually mirrors the plot of
no country
featuring a hunt for a massive amount of
money and three central characters
zipping around in automobiles and
crossing country borders
throughout its tense hours no country
fully
employs noir language if i was into
cutting deals why wouldn't i just deal
with this guy sugar
oh no you don't understand you can't
make a deal with him
even if you gave him the money back he'd
still kill you just for
inconveniencing him so much so that
mitchell argues that the film basically
has
dueling genres with the western
literally facing off against the film
noir
in a way that our villain never fully
faces off with the hero this is seen in
a number of ways
the film quickly abandons the open
desert for the dark interiors of motels
and cars
far more typical of the film noir which
frequently explores themes of lost
morality in the labyrinth of modern life
high contrast lighting also abounds with
many a lone character
sitting in a janky room lit by a long
suffering lamp
there's also extensive use of high and
low angle shots
which serve to disorient us and
disassociate us from our characters
at the same time the film leans heavily
on aggressively intense close-ups
that create a sense of profound
isolation which is only magnified by the
tendency of each character to be alone
on screen
what's more the plot rather than being
straightforward is filled with
cul-de-sacs that serve only to disorient
us like the late introduction of and
near immediate disposal of
carson wells all of the above again are
typical of film noir
viewed this way sheriff bell is
basically a classic western
character airdropped into a neo-western
hence his utter bewilderment at the
violence and depravity that surrounds
him
luellen moss as a revisionist western
character who is morally grey but still
someone you can root for
has also been transported to a
neo-western world
where a fundamental sense of justice
doesn't really exist
instead the film ultimately stays true
to more classic noir themes
that the world is filled with
inexplicable evil and that humans
are helpless against the forces of fate
as scholar christopher wells put it
every film noir is the shadowland of a
lost paradise
a fallen state depicting the american
city's underbelly as
a world of violence and chaos sound
familiar
but the cohen's ultimate subversion of
audience expectations
happens during the climax whether we're
watching a classic
or revisionist western or a comedy
thriller about a diaper-clad senior
executive
we expect the hero and villain to face
off
but instead a random unknown character
takes moss's life
off-screen no showdown with sugar no
reunion with carla jean
just the ultimate narrative blue balls
and this is where we have to talk about
violence in the western typically
violence in classic and to some extent
revisionist western films can bring
about justice
the good guy kills the bad guy and all's
good in the world
but in no country violence does nothing
it's so purposeless in fact that
eventually it just disappears entirely
with both carla jean and llewellyn's
deaths occurring
off-screen with violence ultimately
amounting to nothing
there will be no justice in the cohen's
dark vision of the american west
or will there be later we're teased with
the possibility of a climactic
confrontation
when bell goes back to moss's hotel room
and we see chigurh waiting inside
it's time for a face-off right not so
fast
instead all we get is nothing more than
his shadow on the wall
a nod to the showdown we all wanted the
shot perfectly shows the film's
fundamental tension between western
and noir tropes featuring classic noir
shadows while depicting your typical
western cowboy who has literally become
a shadow of what he once was however
there's
one last opportunity for cosmic justice
when trigger gets into a random car
accident
and we can hear the police approaching
is some kind of higher power providing
justice nope
he just pays off some kids who like all
the other characters
fight over the money and trigger chaos
personified
walks off into the sunset like the
western hero he most
definitely isn't in the end it's a lot
of wtf's for the audience
like bell we don't understand why higher
powers
i.e the filmmakers are denying us any
morally sound sense of justice
if any form of justice prevails it's
triggers who at least makes good on his
promise to kill carla gene
i'm a man of my word this perverted
vision of justice
feels a much more film noir than western
meanwhile
bell is given up essentially admitted
defeat almost as the western
admits defeat in the face of the
nihilism of film noir
later when bell reflects on the
inexplicable crimes
he expresses his desire for meaning from
a higher power
again sounding like a character from a
film noir regretfully looking back
on his life i always figured when i got
older
god would sort of come into my life
somehow
he didn't
i don't blame him
advise him to have the same opinion to
me and he does bell's closing monologue
reflects on our desire to be comforted
with morally satisfying outcomes
but as we're about to see that
won't happen for belle or us because
chaos
but what do you guys think is no country
for old men borrowing from western
tropes only to confound our expectations
by concluding as a film noir
or are the coen brothers just cinema's
most successful trolls
let us know in the comments as always a
big thanks to all our amazing patrons
who support our podcast and channel
hit that subscribe button and as always
peace
[Music]
you